[Camille] Dis-moi Iznogoud,
vu que tu vas faire les courses,
est-ce que tu peux me prendre du boulghour, du quinoa, du tofu, du pain sans gluten et des algues, s'il te plaît ?
[Iznogoud] Han, han
[Camille] C'est bon ? Tu as bien noté ?
[Iznogoud] Ouais, je me l'tatoue directement, ouais c'est plus rapide.
Bon ! Voilà j'y vais je vais au supermarché.
'Fin... A la Biocoop.
Je dois aussi aller au Yoga ce soir.
Yoga
J'ai plus beaucoup de place... Yo-ga.
[Camille] En fait si tu veux, Iznogoud, ici, c'est une asso.
Le concept il est super simple. Tu donnes tes vêtements les plus hypes que tu mets plus
Et ça profite aux miséreux.
[Iznogoud] J'adore le concept.
[Camille] Tu vois, par exemple, ta veste, je la prends,  je la donne à Véro (merci)
Et elle s'occupe du reste.
[Iznogoud] Mais attend, mec !
Mais t'as un coeur énorme en fait !
[Camille] Mais c'est toi qui a un grand coeur ! Tu viens de donner ta veste !
Je suis comme as (comme ça) moi, j'suis comme as ouais.
[Iznogoud] Ooooh ! J'adore cette veste ! Je peux l'essayer ?
[Véro] *étonnée* Oui...
[Iznogoud] Attend mais c'est parfaitement ma taille en plus !
Elle ferait un parfait outfit.
[Camille] Mais, elle te va comme un gant !
[Iznogoud] J'adore cette asso hein !
Alors moi, je connaissais déjà Asos mais pas Asso.
[Camille] Bah tu connais les deux maintenant !
[Iznogoud] Et je connais les deux !!!
[Iznogoud] Camille, tu fais quoi là ?
[Camille] Je fais de la luminothérapie.
[Iznogoud] C'est excellent ! C'est quoi ?
[Camille] Bah en fait, c'est une lampe spéciale qui agit directement sur le cerveau,
grâce à un spectre lumineux très très proche de la lumière du soleil.
[Iznogoud] Ouais.
Alors, il y a un même truc qui est pas mal aussi dans le même genre,
ça s'appelle ouvrir les volets.
Je sais pas si tu...tu connais.
[Camille] Putain, j'avoue !
J'adore le concept ! C'est excellent.
En fait en ce moment, je suis à fond dans l'humanitaire,
avec des potes on a fait un crowdfunding.
Ah vous avez crowdfundé ?
Ouais, on a crowdfundé, ouais.
Et du coup, on a réussit à réunir assez d'argent
pour faire construire un puit dans un lieu défavorisé.
Attends ! Mais on est carrément dans une cité là !
Ouais !
En fait en ce moment, j'essaye de me créer un petit espace feng shui dans ma chambre.
Ah ouais ? C'est quoi ?
Bah en fait, j'essaye d'harmoniser l'énergie environnementale de ma chambre
Pour favoriser mon bien-être
En faisant quelques modifs de meubles.
Ah ouais mais du coup tu dors comment là ?
Bah ! C'est très simple ! Regarde.
J'ai mis mon lit à l'envers,
je me mets comme as tu vois et euh...
Je dors ap.
Putain mais c'est exceeellleent !
C'est du stand-sleeping quoi.
Mais je suis un peu crevé...
Ah mais attend ! T'as un chien, je savais ap.
Non, carrément ap,
c'est mon nouvel animal de compagnie.
Ah ouais carrément fucked up.
J'adore le concept !
Ouais, il s'appelle Wagner
et puis tu vois, lui et moi on est vachement connectés.
Mais attends mec !
Tu trouves pas que c'est un peu touchy de le garder en laisse ?
Tu devrais le libérer, man.
Ouais, t'as raison ! C'est cruel en fait.
Oh ! L'enculé !
Ah ouais ! L'oiseau il a hagar le ver quoi !!
Ah le malaise.
Ah nan mais attends, la nature, elle aime pas la nature en fait.
Mais en fait la nature, c'est une pute.
Eh lunettes ! Viens voir !
En fait, on a tous les deux des lunettes...
Enculé de ta race !
Ah ! Ça c'est peut-être moi ça...
Qui a mis un puit là ?
Alors moi j'ai rien fait. C'est lui. Moi, j'ai juste mis 5 euros dans le crowdfunding, c'est tout.
Frère ! On a déjà de l'eau ! C'est quoi ton délire ?
Euh... ouais mais là, y a carrément plus.
Y a un petit malaise. Moi j'ai Aquabike, je dois y aller.
Moi j'ai carrément Yoga en fait.
Alors là en fait, je t'emmène dans une soirée ultra éphémère. Tu connais ?
Non, je connais ap.
Bah en fait, c'est une soirée qui dure juste un certain laps de temps.
Ok, fais voir.
Ok, c'est parti !
Voilà, c'est terminé. Merci à tous !
C'est excellent, putain !
Camille, je te présente Abricot, ma nouvelle petite copine.
Salut ! Excellent !
Alors, vous êtes quoi ? En couple libre ? En polyamour ? Ou en libertinage ?
Bah en fait, nous on a une vision du sexe et de l'amour complètement nouvelle en fait.
Ouais ?
C'est à dire qu'on a un concept de couple où euh... bah on s'embrasse pas, bah euh on se touche pas d'ailleurs.
Bah en fait on s'aime pas.
Ah.
En fait je veux pas de lui.
Ouais, non, elle veut pas de moi.
Ouais, donc c'est pas ta meuf quoi.
Ouais, non, c'est pas ma meuf en fait.
[Iznogoud] Pourquoi ils nous ont mis là ? Je comprends ap.
[Camille] Ouais moi, je sais pas nager hein.
[Iznogoud] Attends, mais... ce lieu me donne trop envie de faire un after.
[Camille] Mais un Aqua-after même !
Iznogoude ? Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là?
Je fais du son là.
Ah putain c'est excellent !
On peut faire un feat ?
Ah ? Tu veux feater?
Ouais.
Ok,
Alors avec moi. One, two, three, four
♫ J'adore le concept ♫
♫ C'est clairement fucked up ♫
♫ Viens sur mon Tumblr ♫
[Camille] Putain mais c'est excellent !
♫ J'adore le concept ♫
♫ C'est clairement fucked up ♫
♫ Viens sur mon Tumblr ♫
[Camille] En fait moi la vie, je comprends ap.